Welcome back everyone happy comic con week this
will be my brand new superman video there's a
bunch of good news coming to comic con this week
there's been a bunch of news about henry cavill
coming to comic con to talk about the future
of superman so i'll explain what's going on
and what's changed about the superman character at
warner brothers in the movies it's all good news
he would not be coming to comic con if it wasn't
good news so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos i'll
do as many comic-con trailer videos as possible
we have marvel comic-con we're going to get a
black panther 2 trailer we've also got a brand
new black adam trailer of course i'll do videos
for all that stuff there's a bunch of big stuff
dropping this week it'll be great but the past
couple years you probably hear about henry cavill
talk about how he wants to make a new superman
movie like man of steel 2 is what we're kind of
calling it unofficially right now they might call
it something else we also have the new version of
supergirl that they're introducing through the
flash movie next year that they still want to
do something with but the thing that's changed
recently is that warner brothers just got bought
out and the new ceo has this renewed interest
in reviving superman at dc movies like superman
is a bigger priority for them as a character
now than he ever was in the past several years
since the first man of steel batman v superman and
justice league movie you've also probably seen all
the rumors about cameos crossovers and upcoming
dc movies in the next couple of years as well
so because warner brothers has such a renewed
interest in bringing henry cavill back as superman
that's why his chances of coming back literally
just shot through the roof superman style
this is him talking about wanting to make a new
superman movie how he's still got the costume in
the closet he's still ready to go i was very keen
on really fleshing out superman's early stages of
his journey first we had man of steel and then we
went quite a bit darker with batman v superman and
if he were to uh succumb to the anti-life equation
and become bad superman i really wanted to make
sure that we saw the hero superman and we saw this
the true symbol of hope that the beacon of light
before we went down the path of darkness and
then redemption and still something that i am
very keen to flesh out and so what lessons has he
learned he definitely isn't going to kill anymore
and he's definitely going to make sure that
population centers are completely removed from the
equation because now he's experienced it and now
he's thinking about it and so we get those steps
towards building that that incredible wise version
of superman rather than the you know still wet
behind the ears kind so based on what he's saying
there he's got a clear idea of where he wants
superman to go in his next solo movie i'm just
calling his next superman movie man of steel 2
for the purpose of this video they would probably
call it superman man of tomorrow or something more
hopeful but the actual process of him coming back
starts with a lot of these crossovers particularly
in the black adam movie where we're supposed to
see him at the end of that film originally the
rumor was we were going to see a headless cameo
and it was going to be kind of like the shazam
movie and they would kind of wind up doing him
dirty people would be kind of upset like why are
we seeing henry cavill's face but reportedly now
because he is coming to comic-con now everyone's
reporting that we're probably going to see a henry
cavill cameo the way you would expect to see him
like you will know that it's henry cavill it'll be
his face on screen in at comic-con he'll explain
more about some of the other crossovers that he's
working on and eventually doing another superman
solo movie yes there were a lot of rumors about
him joining the marvel universe i think there
was a little bit of time before the big buyout at
warner brothers before they fired a lot of those
people that were working on the dc movies and
brought in a bunch of new people where he's this
really popular actor really in demand and people
like that get a lot of offers so it's just like
if you're not going to make another superman movie
and you don't want to use me in your movies or pay
me what i'm worth then i'll just go to the other
side of the railroad tracks and be in a marvel
movie but because he's coming to the black atom
panel the big warner brothers dc panel i think
that means that he's probably not going to be in
any of these big marvel projects so i wouldn't
worry about any of that but right now there are no
less than four versions of a live action superman
in the upcoming dc movies and hbo series five if
you include tyler heckland superman on superman
at lois in the arrowverse the versions that we
have right now are the multiverse supergirl that
i just mentioned in the flash movie yes the house
of l symbol on her chest looks exactly like henry
cavill's superman symbol so they kind of want you
to think that she's from the main justice league
universe or the same version of krypton that henry
cavill superman came from but here's the thing
if you watch the flash trailer video i'll link
that down in the description below because i've
already done a big video for it but ezra miller's
flash finds her hanging up inside michael keaton's
batcave in a prison cell being bombarded with red
sunlight to weaken her so if he's finding her in
another universe like what is she doing here that
means that in michael keaton's batman universe
earth 89 or whatever you want to call it her pod
probably crashed to earth instead of superman's
or there was a superman at some point either
way she's from michael keaton's batman universe
not the main justice league universe then there's
the new superman movie that warner brothers
announced last year with an african-american
actor playing a version of clark kent superman
i consider that to be a multiverse superman
movie right now and there's a separate michael b
jordan valzod tv series we know a little
bit more about what's going on with that but
that's meant to be a totally different project
from the superman movie that i just mentioned
then obviously you have tyler heckler and superman
in the arrowverse so that's five live-action
different iterations of the superman mythos all on
top of henry cavill superman so we should say that
there's six versions if you include henry cavill
superman if the rumors are to be believed then
he's reportedly coming back in a series of cameos
instead of a straight-up man of steel 2 movie in
the next couple of years the movies that he's been
rumored for are black adam and shazam 2. beyond
that is anyone's guess in the clip that i put at
the beginning of this the story that henry cavill
says that he wants to tell in a new superman movie
like a man of steel 2 movie is basically finishing
the full arc of his character that they started in
the justice league snyder cut now originally zack
snyder was going to cover that full arc in the
justice league trilogy superman's fall to darkness
the anti-life equation that we got a teaser for
then his redemption with him eventually becoming
the true most idealized version of the character
by the end of justice league 3. i've already done
extensive videos on the full plot of what justice
league 2 in justice league 3 would have been zack
snyder thankfully revealed all of his storyboards
and detailed story breakdowns so i'll add a link
for that video at the end of this and down in the
description below because it's crazy but it sounds
really cool based on what zack snyder has told us
though since the snyder cut came out the studio
doesn't really seem interested in finishing his
justice league trilogy he said that he would do it
just as soon as they green lit it but they haven't
come close to doing that so the last we got from
henry cavill's superman arc was the cliffhanger
with the nightmare ending scene with evil superman
getting ready to kill batman and the remnants of
the justice league and the villains working with
them that whole post-credit scene with batman
and martian manhunter was meant to sort of
walk that dark alternate future back just a little
and say hey here's what we're gonna do differently
in this timeline in this time loop flash would
have eventually been able to travel back into
the past to warn batman that we saw a version of
earlier in batman v superman batman would have
made the correct moves in the new time loop they
would have been able to save superman from falling
to dark side of the anti-life equation and use the
big team upgrade with the justice league to defeat
darkseid for good like i said the link for that
full video on justice league 2 and justice league
3 plot will be at the end of this and down in the
description below it gets way twistier and way
crazier with a billion other characters you will
not believe the giant twist they were going to
have at the end of that too like the post-credits
scene for justice league 3. i believe the original
plan was for them to do man of steel then do
man of steel 2 but because of the box office
performance of the first band of steel movie
they decided to turn man of steel 2 into batman
v superman and make it a batman movie as well if
you remember several years ago there was like a
whole different movie slate they had planned out
for like the next 10 years of dc movies you could
go down that rabbit hole if you want but i think
they're just afraid to make another henry cavill
superman movie thinking that it won't earn the
amount of money that they wanted to that's why
you see 10 batman movies for every one superman
movie right now realistically the best odds of
henry cavill coming back as superman in a big
way are actually probably through the black adam
sequels because the rock is super keen to do black
adam versus superman he will not stop talking
about it he even posts a giant clip of it when
he was teasing the black adam movie i can't wait
to show you more you know i always thought that
it might be cool to hang out with superman that
would be cool right i mean we're kind of similar
in terms of our powers our strengths our speeds
because look at the end of the day you never
know black adam and superman could become friends
or they won't who knows maybe we'll see but before
i go i want you guys to help me out with something
it's something that's pretty important i need
you guys to help me get a message out to uh
to some of the other ones some
of the other dc superheroes
let's let flash shazam aquaman wonder woman batman
and superman let's let them know something things
will never be the same because the hierarchy
of power in the dc universe is about to change
so clearly you can see the rock has this vested
interest in doing a lot with the zack snyder
versions of the justice league characters if he
were to tell warner brothers hey i want henry
cavill's superman in black adam to pay him his
money they would do it so let me know in the
comments what do you actually want them to do
with the new henry cavill superman solo movie
all my con videos will be posting
in the next couple of days make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of that footage
everyone click here for my brand new black
panther 2 doctor doom video and click here
for my brand new black adam comic con trailer
i'll update the link as soon as i post that
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!